[Music]
[Applause]
we've loved you in so many different
projects could you ever see a Hannah
Montana being rebooted oh gosh I know
it's it's been talked about for many
years I don't I don't know if it would
ever happen I feel like I was I guess we
did four seasons five annual years it
was a big part of our lives and to think
you gave him the best 14 years of your
life yours you will never get back
exactly I feel like we did wrap it up in
a way that felt final but I think if we
ever did it again we'd have to do a
resurgence of some new story that we'd
never done before and I think it'd be
hard to talk because I feel like we
should just let it let it be what it was
Emily Osment closed that chapter as Lily
on Hannah Montana in 2011 and has
welcomed a new role opposite Michael
Douglas in Netflix's the Kaminski method
I play a woman named Theresa who's sort
of fresh-faced and new to acting and she
takes acting lessons from Michael
Douglas's caret character sandy and
she's sort of coming into her own acting
wise and she's one of those girls that
sort of just needs the right push in the
right direction and she'll probably get
there do you feel like working with
Betty help you prepare at any moment
here talking about Betty White who's
framed in my office yes I have a picture
of us me wearing a wedding dress and
Betty I think also wearing a wedding
dress yeah she's she's incredible yeah
it's a it's a good lesson and just being
patient and and working with people who
have been around a long time you notice
how they're nice to everybody they talk
to everybody they make eye contact with
everybody you know there's no sort of
jaded atmosphere it's just like this is
what I do this is what I'm good at and
and what can I take from these people
it's it's really cool with season 2
coming up is there anyone that is a
guest star that's on your wish list I'd
love to work with Julie anymore I think
she's amazing she's been an idol of mine
for a long time to make that great let's
make it happen
you